I had somebody in the room who let me
know that Jamie had a blood clot in his
brain after he got the shot he did not
want the shot but the movie he was on he
was pressured to get it we do not know
yet from anybody in his family that
there's any ferocity to the claims that
are being made by AJ benza but what we
can say is that they have not disputed
the claims well Jamie Foxx's rep is
slamming those claims about the actor's
Health now in a statement to E.T nearly
two months after Jaime was hospitalized
after suffering a medical emergency
onset of his film back in Action details
about what happened still remain a
mystery but that hasn't stopped internet
sleuths from speculating one including
gossip columnist AJ benza who made a
claim on ask Dr Drew that Jamie's health
issue was caused by the covet vaccine
what I found out from the man in the
room was that the blood clot in the
brain caused him at that point to be
partially paralyzed and and blind I had
somebody in the room who let me know
that Jamie had a blood clot in his brain
after he got the shot he did not want
the shot but the movie he was on he was
pressured to get it and I'm thinking is
that why he blew up on the set a week
before this medical emergency happened
is that why he fired three or four
people because he just had had it with
these mandates commentator Candice Owens
also jumped in on this convo saying she
thinks Jamie's family's silence means
there's some truth to it that this was
my family and a person went out and told
a viral lie that I suffered a blood clot
in my brain because of the covid-19
vaccine we would immediately issue a
statement their silence seems as though
they are suggesting that there is some
verocity to this claim however Jaime's
reptiles E.T they're completely
inaccurate in May his daughter Corinne
shared that he's been out of the
hospital for weeks and recoup rating
this update seemed due to reports
surfacing that the family Was preparing
for the worst as of now Jamie's
currently undergoing physical
rehabilitation in Chicago the rehab
centers pretty much address any motor or
any cognitive or language impairment
that can potentially result from either
a condition like stroke or brain injury
or any other condition so really without
knowing exactly what happened to him one
thing's for sure Jamie has lots of love
and support from his friends and
co-stars nothing but love for Jamie I
mean I wish him the besties in my
prayers every night he's not only one of
our best entertainers we have out here
but he's a great person and he's a
genuine person so please pray for him I
just hope that truly he feels that he's
blessed and everybody is praying for his
health and speedy recovery so I think
it's such a wonderful person he brings
so much light and laughter into this
world and I just hope in times like this
he feels it back that we think about him
and we pray for him